Donald Trump within minutes an hour of
Joe Biden's brutal speech condemning his
inciting of the Trump riots a year ago
yesterday published a statement riddled
with random capitalization
and lies and all of the things we have
come accustomed to seeing from the
former president let's take a look at
that statement Donald Trump saying quote
Biden who is destroying our nation with
insane policies of open Capital borders
corrupt capital E elections disastrous
energy policies unconstitutional
mandates and devastating school closures
used my name today to try to further
divide America
this political theater is all just a
distraction from the fact Biden has
completely and totally failed our
Capital C country no longer has capital
B borders that's not true has totally
and completely lost control of covet
record numbers we are seeing record
numbers the world is is no longer
capital e i energy independent capital I
inflation is rampant our capital and
Military is in chaos and our exit or
Surrender from Afghanistan was perhaps
the most embarrassing day in the long
and distinguished History of the United
States and so much more remember that
Trump had no better plan for Afghanistan
whenever we got out it was going to be
chaos at least Joe Biden got us out as
I've said before
why is it that the unselect committee of
totally Pardons and partisan political
hacks whose judgment has long ago been
made not discussing the rigged
presidential election of 2020 because it
wasn't rigged and it's not their charge
that's not what the committee is doing
it's because they don't have the answers
or justifications for what happens as
Trump they got away with something and
it is leading to our Capital C countries
destruction they all want they want all
conversation concerning the capital E
election Capital C canceled just look at
the numbers they speak for themselves
they are not justifiable so the
complicit media just calls it the big
lie when in actuality the big lie was
the capital E election itself as many
instances of out and out lying here
about Biden's policy
uh and all of these other things as much
as there is random capitalization Donald
Trump highly highly triggered which
suggests to me that Joe Biden really hit
a nerve it was the right decision for
Trump to cancel his press conference
yesterday because as triggered as he was
I can only imagine he would have
completely humiliated himself had he
actually taken questions from reporters
so that is it Biden on the one-year
anniversary of the riots and Trump on
the one-year anniversary of the riots
we're going to take a quick break uh
find me on Twitter at dpacman we will be
right back
even if like me you're not vegan and
you're not vegetarian eating a more
plant-based diet is a really great thing
to do for a number of different reasons
and our sponsor just egg is the
delicious plant-based egg you can use it
anywhere you use traditional eggs
because the taste and texture are
identical but just eggplant-based eggs
have the same amount of protein as
traditional eggs I use it all the time
at home you can make fluffy scrambled
eggs you can make omelettes you can make
quiche frittata Crepes fried rice you
should see my fried rice recipe you can
really use it anywhere in baking or
anywhere you would use traditional eggs
when I first tried just egg I was
surprised that a plant-based egg could
both taste and cook just like
traditional eggs you can get it at the
grocery store instacart Amazon go try it
eating a more plant-based diet is a
great decision I do it and I'm not vegan
or vegetarian and just egg makes it that
much more easy and delicious